-Making his U.S. TV debut,
performing "Love Nwantiti"
and "Emiliana,"
here's CKay!
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Mm mm ♪
♪ Ah da ♪
♪ Ah da da ♪
♪ My baby, my valentine, yeah ♪
♪ Girl, na you dey make
my temperature dey rise ♪
♪ If you leave me, I go die,
I swear ♪
♪ You are like the oxygen
I need to survive ♪
♪ I'll be honest ♪
♪ Your loving dey totori me ♪
♪ I am so obsessed ♪
♪ I want to chop your nkwobi ♪
-♪ Ule ♪
-♪ Your body dey gbakam isi ♪
-♪ Open am make I see ♪
♪ Ule, nyem love nwantiti ♪
♪ Wey fit make a bad man sing,
oh, ah ah ah ♪
♪ Ah ah ah ah ah ah ♪
♪ Ah ah ah ah
ah ah ♪
♪ Ah ah ah ah ah ♪
♪ Ah ah ah ah ah ah ♪
♪ Ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ♪
♪ Oh oh oh oh oh ♪
-♪ Ah ah ah ah ah ah ♪
♪ Ah ah ah ah ah ah ♪
-♪ Ah ah ah ah ah ♪
-♪ Ah ah ah ah ah ah ♪
-♪ Oh oh oh oh oh ♪
-♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪
♪ Baby, tell me,
where you from? Come ♪
♪ If I do na follow come, yeah ♪
♪ No be silicon ♪
♪ Baba God e finish work,
ah da da da da ♪
♪ Without you,
I go fit lose my mind ♪
♪ Without you, I go
fit fall and die ♪
♪ Without you,
I go give up my life ♪
♪ Without you ♪
-♪ Ule ♪
-♪ Your body dey gbakam isi ♪
-♪ Open am make I see ♪
♪ Ule, nyem love nwantiti ♪
♪ Wey fit make a bad man sing,
oh, ah ah ah ♪
♪ Ah ah ah ah ah ah ♪
♪ Ah ah ah ah ah ♪
♪ Oh oh oh oh oh ♪
♪ Ah ah ah ah ah ah ♪
-♪ Ah ah ah ah ah ♪
-♪ Ah ah ah ah ah ah ♪
-♪ Oh oh oh oh oh ♪
-♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪
♪♪
♪ Ah da da da ♪
♪ All because of you ♪
♪ I be on the phone
all night long, oh ♪
♪ No be small ting ♪
♪ The way you do it to me,
oh, no, no, no ♪
♪ I be on my business, shawty ♪
♪ But you be on my mind,
shawty ♪
♪ Ebelebe oloma,
my honey, ah ah ♪
♪ Kiss me through the cellular ♪
♪ Kiss me through the phone ♪
♪ Can't you see I'm
into ya? ♪
♪ Can't you see I'm in love? ♪
♪ Kiss me through the cellular ♪
♪ Kiss me through the phone ♪
♪ You're messin'
with my medulla ♪
♪ High-key, I don kolo, oh, no ♪
♪ Emiliana, oh, Emiliana ♪
♪ Oh, Emiliana, oh, no ♪
♪ You're one in a million,
oh, in a million ♪
♪ Oh, in a million, oh, no ♪
♪ My Emiliana, oh, Emiliana ♪
♪ Oh, Emiliana, oh, no ♪
♪♪
♪ Ya ya ya ya ya ah ya ♪
♪ Ah ah ah ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]